you
hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar current controversies and
epidemiology diagnosis and management of
vaginal infections
I am Alexis Krause of laberd's and I'll
be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by lab birds and brought to
you by roche molecular diagnostics to
learn more about our sponsor please
visit www.hp.com/recycle we encourage
you to participate by submitting as many
questions as you want at any time you
want during the presentation to do so
simply type them into the ask a question
box and click send we'll answer as many
questions as we have time for at the end
of the presentation if you have trouble
seeing or hearing the presentation click
on the support tab found at the top
right of the presentation window or
report your problem by clicking on the
ask a question box located on the far
left your screen this presentation is
educational and thus offers continuing
education credits please click on the
continuing education credits tab located
at the top right of the presentation
window and follow the process to save
your credits I now present today's
speaker dr. Kristina
Mosley associate professor medicine
infectious diseases University of
Alabama at Birmingham School of Medicine
for a complete biography on our speaker
please visit the biography tab at the
top of your screen dr. Massey you may
now begin your presentation thank you so
much good morning everyone I'm excited
to do this webinar today and I have to
apologize at the very beginning because
I have a little bit of a cold so I'm
going to try not to cough but it may
happen so as mentioned the title of this
presentation is current controversies
and the epidemiology diagnosis and
management of vaginal infections and as
you all know this can include BV
trichomonas
and vaginal yeast infections because of
our time constraint today I'm mainly
going to focus on trichomonas and BV for
the purpose of this presentation I have
several disclosures which are listed on
this slide
I am currently involved in a BB
pathogenesis study as well as a
trichomonas treatment trial which I will
mention the results during this
presentation and I'm also a consultant
for lupin pharmaceuticals
to talk about several controversies with
regards to trichomoniasis
I picked three out of the many
controversies that are currently being
discussed regarding trichomonas that I
wanted to talk to you all about today
and the first is should we be screening
all women for trichomoniasis and if so
with what test the second which
treatment is best for all women and that
gets to this trichomonas treatment trial
that we recently published the results
on just last month in October which
talks about whether or not the two
Graham stat dos and metronidazole or the
seven-day metronidazole dose is more
highly efficacious and finally we're
getting a lot of cases of refractory
trichomoniasis that seem to be happening
more often and I wanted to mention that
towards the end because the treatment of
that is also somewhat controversial
so just to start off talking about
screaming I did want to mention some new
epidemiological data that was just
published a couple of months ago in
clinical infectious diseases from the
Johns Hopkins group and this looked at
the epidemiology of trichomonas in u.s.
men and women in the in Haines cycle
from 2013 to 2014 and this was the first
time actually that men were included for
trichomonas testing in any of the in
Haines studies so that was a novel part
of this to begin with it was also the
first time that people were tested for
trichomonas with the ha logic gen-probe
Optima trichomonas vaginalis nucleic
acid amplification test and they found
in this study as you can see on the
slide that the prevalence among us women
was 1.8% in men was 0.5% and these were
ages 18 to 59
with regards to trichomonas it was
significantly associated with female sex
black race older age having less than a
high school education being below the
poverty level and having greater than
two sexual partners in the past year
there is a very pronounced racial
disparity for this infection in the
black population which exceeds that of
nationally observed data for chlamydia
hsv-2
and HPV it's important to also note that
these prevalence estimates exceed
estimates of trichomonas and other
high-income countries such as the UK
I also want to mention some
epidemiological data from Alabama at our
Jefferson County Department of Health
STD clinic interestingly this clinic was
one of the first STD clinics in the
country to implement routine screening
for trichomonas with the whole logic
abdomen that several years ago now back
in 2011-2012 this was started and so we
had a unique opportunity to review the
medical records of these patients to see
the burden of trichomonas in this clinic
population and I want to say we see
about 18,000 patients a year at this
clinic so basically everybody that comes
to this clinic gets screened for
trichomonas if they're symptomatic or
asymptomatic with this nucleic acid
amplification test so we were able to
review charts from over 2,500 men and
almost 4,000 women between the period of
2012 and 2013 that was basically the
first year that both of these groups
were screened at this clinic we found
that the overall prevalence was very
high at 20% basically one out of every
four patients coming to this clinic had
trichomonas infection um and when we
looked at it stratified by gender 27
percent in women and 9 point 8 percent
in men
the correlates of trichomonas and women
were older age again african-american
race having white blood cells on a wet
mount an elevated vaginal pH of positive
with tests and being Co infected with
gonorrhea in men it was also older age
african-american race and having greater
than 5 p.m. ends on a urethral Gram
stain and it's important to note that in
this study we also do what mount at this
clinic by the way for women but it's
important to note that using the
trichomonas mat we detected a third more
trick most infections in women than
using wet mount alone
however despite the high prevalence of
trichomonas nationally and here in
Alabama trichomonas is a neglected STI
and there are several reasons for this
there are no established screening
surveillance or control programs for
women or men for trichomonas in the
United States right now in the 2015 CDC
STD treatment guidelines which is our
most recent published guidelines routine
screening is only recommended in
hiv-positive women at entry to care and
then annually screening is considered
for persons and other high prevalence
settings which I have listed here and
asymptomatic persons at high risk but
this is not consistently done throughout
the country
so why are we not having screening
recommendations and why do we have a
lack of national surveillance for
trichomonas so this is a very
controversial issue and basically there
are seven criteria to be a nationally
reportable disease which I have listed
on this slide
so you need to have a very frequent
prevalent disease it has to have
associated disparities or inequities it
has to be communicable it has to have
severity associated with it associated
cost to the healthcare system means to
prevent it and public interests in
decreasing rates of this infection and
there's a very interesting paper written
in the sexually transmitted diseases
Journal in 2013 which I have listed on
the bottom of the slide if you're ever
interested in reading this paper that
kind of discusses which of these
criteria that the authors thought
trichomonas fulfills which was only
three out of these seven they thought it
is a frequent disease there are
disparities particularly in the
african-american population and we do
know that it's an STD so it is
communicable however there's a lot of
controversy about the severity of
trichomonas and its associated
complications a lot of people think that
trichomonas is mainly seen an
asymptomatic patient not necessarily
everyone is symptomatic and there's some
debate about whether or not trichomonas
causes complications such as preterm
birth and acquisition of HIV and other
STDs this has not been studied in detail
associated cost with trichomonas is not
also well studied so it's hard to make a
determination on that criteria there's
no data on whether a national control
program could reduce trichomonas
prevalence and in this 2013 STD paper
they were basically stating that there's
a lot of issues with chlamydia
national control programs that are
currently going on and so they had major
concerns that trichomonas would have
simul
our issues and also apparently there's a
lack of public interest in trichomonas
but I personally have to say if there
you know I don't if the public doesn't
know about it
how do we know whether or not they have
interest in it I mean we hear about HIV
a lot and syphilis a lot and genital
herpes in public advertisements and we
hear about antibiotic resistant
gonorrhea we don't see as much we don't
hear as much about trichomonas and so
it's hard to gauge what the public
interest is in trichomonas
you
in addition not all successful STI
control measures are currently being
used for trichomonas to help decrease
its high prevalence so I have listed
here all many STI control measures that
have been successful in the past for
other esti is this is yousef sensitive
screening test so trichomonas we do have
the nucleic acid amplification test but
they're not being widely used a lot of
STD clinics and other clinics are mainly
using wet mounts some clinics are using
nucleic acid amplification tests but the
majority of clinics that I've talked to
that are using them are mainly using
them in women perhaps in symptomatic
heterosexual men but that's not
standardized also another successful
measure is availability of effective
affordable medicines which metronidazole
ways to treat trichomonas is the most
affordable treatment for any sexually
transmitted infection accurate reporting
of cases is currently not available for
trichomonas because it's not a
nationally reportable disease and
initiation of mandatory reporting to the
CDC is not done because right now
they're saying it only meets three out
of the seven criteria which I just
reviewed and then treatment of infective
partners which is basically expedited
partner therapy it's not clear to me
right now how often this is being done
for trichomonas EPT is permissible in
the majority of US states but not all
states and just from anecdotally talking
to other people I have been told that
EPT is mainly being done more for
chlamydia and gonorrhea than it is for
trichomoniasis my next slide shows the
legal status of expedited partner
therapy across the country this is from
the CDC website and this is updated and
as you can see the majority of states
across the country are green which is
the permissible color meaning that EPT
is permissible in that state
unfortunately right now my state Alabama
is potentially allowable even though
that they say that it is potentially
allowable
Health Department clinics while we are
screening all men and all women that
come to clinic for trichomonas with the
Nats we are not doing we are not allowed
to do EPT at our clinics here in the
state there are two states Kentucky and
South Carolina where it is prohibited
I think for those four criteria that
trichomonas is said not to currently
meet I think we need some additional
data to help support that trichomonas
meets those criteria to help push the
fact that we need to have this to be a
nationally reportable disease and to
start routinely screening all women and
perhaps men in the country
the second the second thing I want to
talk about is if we are screening people
what tests are we going to use well for
the most part in the past the wet mode
has been the most commonly used test for
trichomonas this is a rapid
point-of-care test that is very cheap it
I do want to note that it must be
performed in ten to twenty minutes after
you get a vaginal vaginal specimen
collection or the trichomonas
will lose viability and then we can see
the organism on the wet mount under the
microscope this test the main problem
with it is that it has very low
sensitivity even in the best of hands
however the specificity when you see the
trick amount of swimming on the slide is
a very good specificity
another rapid point-of-care test that we
have available is the awesome test stick
which is a rapid antigen test for
trichomonas this can be performed on
vaginal secretions it uses antibodies to
detect trichomonas protein antigens it
has a higher sensitivity than the wet
mount at 83% with a specificity of 97%
it has not been validated in men to date
so this has only been used in women a
positive test shows that you have
detection of trichomonas antigen as
determined on this as shown in this
picture on the slide with a red control
line you can get the results in 10
minutes so it can be done in clinic
while the patient is waiting it is more
expensive than a wet mount when I looked
up the cost online it appears to be
about $12 per test and you also have to
buy a positive control kit which I saw
was priced at approximately $40
trichomonas can be seen on papsmear that
women are having for cervical cancer
screening I get a few occasional calls
every year from people that got a pap
smear result with trichomonas on it and
they asked me what I need to do and I
always tell them if you see trichomonas
on a pap smear it's there and you
definitely need to treat the patient so
I don't think people are using pap
smears to screen for trichomonas but I
think if you see it on there you should
treat for it and I have the sensitivity
and specificity in the conventional paps
and the liquid based pops mentioned on
this slide as you can see
the trichomonas culture has been the
gold standard for diagnosis
traditionally this is where you
inoculate a swab of vaginal fluids into
the in pouch culture and you basically
have to incubate that at 37 degrees and
it has to be read multiple times over
three to five days to see if you see
trichomonas under the microscope
so this does represent a lot of
substantial delays between obtaining the
swab from the patient and getting the
final test results especially if it has
to be read up to five days here again
the sensitivity is a hundred percent
with asbestos specificity forty four to
seventy-five percent on this line
it's also important to note when you
want to do susceptibility testing you
need to do a trichomonas culture so you
can culture the parasite to be able to
do the susceptibility testing on it
so I wanted to briefly mention these
nucleic acid amplification test because
we have several now which is really
exciting for this field the first one
that I mentioned which we use at our
clinic and was used in the in Haynes
data is the hajeck Optima trichomonas
NAT which was the first fda-approved NAT
for use in women it can be used in men
if your lab internally validates it it
is not currently fda-approved in men so
here in Alabama our lab are helped our
central health department lab has
validated this test which is how we can
use it for patient care and give results
to patients it has excellent sensitivity
and specificity and the assay
performance is similar in asymptomatic
and symptomatic women in the studies we
do use it on urine specimens we also use
it on vaginal specimens and cervical
specimens that are collected I have been
told that this test cost about 90
dollars but it is important to note that
the test is also being used for
gonorrhea and chlamydia nucleic acid
amplification testing so there all
you're getting basically for ninety
dollars you're getting all three of
these organisms tested for
the next map which was published and
became FDA approves in 2014 which it was
the BD probe tech trichomonas NAT and in
this study published in the journal
clinical microbiology it was found to
have superior performance to the wet
mount and it was found to be equivalent
with the Optima trichomonas NAT I
haven't told that this test is slightly
cheaper than the ha logic optimal test
which could be a benefit
but neither of these tests are rapid
point-of-care tests
recently however we've had the Cepheid
expert trichomonas nucleic acid
amplification test which was
fda-approved in women and men in 2017
the paper on that study was just
published earlier this year in the
Journal of Clinical microbiology this is
a very large study that looked at the
assay in women and men so it's important
to note that this assay is fda-approved
in men as well as women and it's also
important to note that the assay can
provide on-demand results in 63 minutes
or less with early termination for
positive results within 40 minutes so
this assay could be used for diagnosis
in real-time clinics if patients are
willing to wait 40 to 60 minutes for
their test results this test can also
the swab for this test is also being
used for gonorrhea and chlamydia
detection and I'm told that the cost for
the Cepheid mat is around 130 dollars so
out of the three nets this test is the
most expensive however it is
fda-approved in men and you can get
faster test results which could
potentially be used in real time if you
have a machine running this test in your
clinic so if you ask if we're screening
all women and potentially men what tests
should we use well we have a large
number of tests and you know to
determine that the best test with the
highest sensitivity and specificity are
the Nats
however cost is obviously much more than
a webmail or a rapid antigen test so you
have to weigh the pros and cons of all
of these different diagnostic tests for
your budget constraints your time and
clinic and the time that patients are
willing to sit and wait for their test
results or if they want to leave the
clinic and get their test results call
to them later
so I want to spend the second part of
the trichomonas section talking about
treatment because this is evolving over
time as per the 2015 CDC STD treatment
guidelines the preferred regimen are the
stat doses the two grams of
metronidazole or ten it is old and the
alternative regimen is 500 milligrams
twice daily of metronidazole for seven
days it is important to note that this
regimen of seven days is the preferred
regiment for hiv-positive women in the
2015 CDC STD treatment guidelines and
that recommendation was based on a
randomised controlled trial now that was
published back in 2010 from a study done
in Houston Texas New Orleans Louisiana
and Jackson Mississippi that found that
the seven-day metronidazole dose and
hiv-positive women with trichomoniasis
was more highly efficacious than the two
gram stat dose and in this study it was
thought that co-infection with bacterial
vaginosis was one factor that was
associated with early failure of the
single dose treatment it is well known
that we treat BV for with seven days of
metronidazole currently so intuitively
it makes sense that if you're also
co-infected with BV
the seven-day dose of metro nozzle also
treated trichomonas better
you
a meta-analysis was recently done for
all of the studies looking at the two
gram stat dose and metronidazole versus
the seven-day dose in all women and this
was published last year in the STD
Journal I have to get a small drink of
water I'm sorry this meta-analysis
looked at seven studies including that
one study for the hiv-positive women
which I just mentioned that was
published in 2010-2011 but dr. Kissinger
in New Orleans this meta-analysis found
that overall between all seven of these
studies the seven-day metronidazole dose
seemed to be more highly efficacious for
all women not just HIV positive women
leading to the suggestion that perhaps
we should make the seven-day dose the
preferred regimen for all women however
until recently we did not have a robust
randomized control trial looking at the
2 gram stat dose versus the seven-day
dose head-to-head in HIV uninfected
women that leads me into our study that
was published just last month and The
Lancet Infectious Disease it's currently
electronically published online if
you're interested in looking at the
study and this was comparing those two
doses head-to-head and HIV uninfected
women and so our clinic here in
Birmingham was very integral in to this
study we enrolled over 400 women here
and they enrolled an additional 200 plus
women in Jackson Mississippi in New
Orleans Louisiana
as you can see women were recruited for
this study between October 2014 up until
April of 2017 they were randomized in a
one-to-one fashion to one of these
medications and the primary outcome of
the study was trichomonas infection by
intention-to-treat intensive care for
weeks after completion of treatment and
women were diagnosed in this study up by
the nat and/or culture
the analysis of this primary outcome was
also stratified by BV status given the
results of that 2010 hiv-positive study
that I mentioned and BV in this study
was defined by Nugent score on a vaginal
Gram stain on this next slide you can
see the baseline characteristics of the
intent to treat population there was not
any significant differences between the
seven-day the baseline characteristics
of women in the seven-day dose group or
the single dose metronidazole group
in this next slide you can see that we
assessed over a thousand patients for
eligibility in this study a total of 623
randomly assigned to the treatment
groups as I mentioned about 400 here at
UAB it is important to mention that
self-reported adherence was high in the
single dose group which was given as
directly observed therapy in the clinic
but also high in the seven-day dose
group at 96%
these percentages were not significantly
different between groups side effects
were also similar break group and here
in this table - which is the primary
outcome and sensitivity analysis you can
see that women with this first red
circle on the slide women who received
the seven-day dose of metronidazole had
a 45 percent reduction in their risk of
having recurrent trichomoniasis at their
test of care visits so basically the
7-day metronidazole dose was more highly
efficacious in women that were treated
with this dose compared to the 2 gram
stat dose in contrast to the
hiv-positive study BV status had no
effect on the relative risk in this
study
were some people who had concerns that
we were basing the test of care status
on that as part of our analyses so we
did a separate sensitivity analysis in
the study where we used only trichomonas
culture positive culture at tests of
cure as you can see in the second red
circle at the bottom of the slide and in
the sensitivity analysis our initial
study findings still held up basically
saying that the seven-day dose was more
highly efficacious than the two gram
stat dose and HIV uninfected women
several implications for this new
treatment study basically there is now
good data to suggest that the seven-day
metronidazole dose should be the
preferred dose for all women not just
hiv-positive women up based on this RCT
and the meta-analysis which I mentioned
in addition as I mentioned in the
current and Haynes data we have a very
large ongoing burden of trichomonas in
women so we want to treat these women
with the best medications that we have
possible however there have been some
concerns about going to a 7-day regimen
over a stat dose for the preferred
regimen there are people that are
concerned that treatment adherence
issues could impact this in our
randomized control trial treatment
adherence was not a problem in the
seven-day dose group but that was a
highly controlled clinical trial setting
and there's not a lot of data in the
real world on this topic so we're going
to be investigating that going forward
to get some data with that also right
now the current recommendation to treat
men which are common Isis is with two
grams stat metronidazole there is no RCT
data at all in men comparing the two
grams versus the 7-days that is robust
so if women are treated with 7 days but
men are still treated with 2 days and we
counsel all of them to refrain from sex
there could be a conflict in the timing
of abstinence from sex which could put
the couple at risk for re exposure so
counseling is going to need to be very
important if we're going to be treating
women and men differently for the same
STD moving forward until we have data
for men it's also unclear how this will
affect EPT for trichomonas trichomonas
vaginalis so we have a review article on
these implications of this study that is
currently at a journal so hopefully that
can get published in the next couple of
months if you're interested in looking
for that for the future because it goes
into detail about some of these issues
one other thing I wanted to talk about
is a new medication called Cigna diesel
which is in the same drug class as
metronidazole and ten it is all for
trichomoniasis significant has a longer
half-life than metronidazole Anton is
all which makes it attractive to use as
a one-time dose and so there there are
going to be some studies coming up in
the future of looking at significant
treatment of trichomoniasis it was
recently FDA approved in the United
States for treatment of bacterial
vaginosis so we're curious if signal can
also be used for the treatment of
trichomoniasis with a longer half-life
and perhaps if we do find some good data
for this we could go back to a single
one-time dose of a medication for
trichomoniasis but right now based on
the current data it looks like we're
headed towards a seven-day dose of
metronidazole filing last thing in the
trichomonas section I want to talk about
is refractory trichomoniasis and this is
where women are persistently infected
basically we need to distinguish this
from reinfection from an untreated
sexual partner so obviously a very good
history for a patient that comes back
that still has persistent trichomonas
infection is needed
basically these are patients that come
in they have trick we give them either a
2 gram stat dose or seven-day dose they
say they take it but they come back to
clinic a couple weeks later still with
complaints and they're still found to
have trichomonas and that's when we get
into this issue I do want to mention
that based on the data that we do have
resistance to the 5 nitro medicines
which is going to be metronidazole
Tonetta so right now is not very high
it's about four point three to five
percent based on this most recent study
now six years ago from the STD
surveillance network this is from six
STD clinics across the country and so it
looks like the majority of resistance in
this study of trichomonas isolates which
had 538 isolates in this study with
low-level resistance to metronidazole
there was no high level resistance seen
in this study and it appears that low
level metronidazole resistance can be
overcome by using - knitters all so
basically right now the recommendations
in the setting of dosing for drug
resistance and persistent infection if
your patient was first treated with
trichomonas with two grams and
metronidazole you would want to avoid
Rideau seing them with that same single
dose so you would go ahead and give them
for the second round of treatment 500
milligrams twice a day for seven days if
this does not work and they still have
trichomonas you would want to consider
performing susceptibility testing on the
isolate if your lab does that that's
great or you can send it to the cdc to
be done they're also at that time you
would want to give metronidazole orton
it is all at a hot at the two-gram dose
instead of a stat dose you would want to
give it longer for five to seven days in
addition there is some anecdotal data
about intravaginal parama mice and
creams in combination with high dose 10
it is all intravaginal boric acid or not
as Oxendine
it is important to note that these
intravaginal preparations have to be
made in a compounding pharmacy and they
can get pretty expensive for patients so
you can't just call Walmart or CVS and
order these medications you have to
order them at a compound compounding
form seeing the patient has to pick them
up
in addition high-dose tinnitus all at
two to three grams daily in combination
with intravaginal tune it is all twice
daily for 14 days may also be useful in
these settings I have listed on this
slide some other medications that have
been tried mainly intravaginal
preparations that are not currently
recommended and all these
recommendations are currently listed in
the 2015 CDC STD treatment guidelines
there is no consensus for the treatment
of refractory trichomoniasis so
basically these are some recommendations
but there's no good randomized
controlled data for these patients so
I'm going to move quickly to bacterial
vaginosis and mention a couple of
controversies for BV and shift gears for
us obviously the number one controversy
for BV is what causes B B we still don't
know the exact etiology I could actually
talk about that for hours I'm just going
to mention it for just a few minutes
here it's still a little controversial
if BV is an STD or not I think the
majority of epidemiological data points
to the fact that it is and so the main
thing right now is that what is causing
baby also how to prevent high BV
recurrence rates which we see all the
time women with recurrent BV and finally
another controversy is should we treat
sexual partners of women would B be
particularly in the setting of where
we're concerned that it's an STD
so Bibi is the most common cause of
vaginal discharge in women it has
multiple complications as I have listed
on this slide and it is known that Bibi
is characterized by depletion of lactic
acid producing lactose and increases in
gardnerella vaginalis which is a
facultative anaerobe and other strict
anaerobes however its etiology and
incubation period remain unknown but the
epidemiology strongly supports that it
is acquired via sexual transmission
I have several bullet points listed on
this slide
that are epidemiological data that are
in support of Bibi being sexually
transmitted I'm not going to read
through all of these on this webinar
because of time constraint but you're
more than welcome to go back and look at
this slide there's a great review
article that I have listed at the bottom
of the slide that goes into details for
some of these original studies which are
referenced in that article if you want
to go back and read more about that our
group does have a model hypothesis for
the etiology of BV there are several
competing hypotheses some people think
that it's one bacteria particularly
gardnerella vaginalis we call that the
primary pathogen model there are other
people that think that Bibi is sexually
transmitted by a poly microbial
consortium of microorganisms
that's the polymicrobial pathogen model
there's a paper here in the Journal of
infectious diseases in 2014 that's
listed on this slide that goes into
detail about these two models and the
pros and cons of each there's also a
lactobacillus depletion model which is
not discussed in this paper on this
slide but it is discussed in other
papers you may see something about that
out in the literature some people think
that just losing your lactose without
introduction of a pathogen can perhaps
lead to BV the
gnosis OBB in clinical care as you all
know is made by the Amstel criteria
three out of four of these criteria are
needed for diagnosis which I have the
criteria listed on the slide clue cells
on a wet marginal fluid or one of these
criteria Clouseau obviously is a vat of
squamous epithelial cell that's left off
from the vaginal canal that's coated
with all of these facultative and strict
anaerobic bacteria in research settings
we diagnose bv more rigorously using the
Nugent score from a vaginal Gram stain
which I have pictures of different
scoring categories for Nugent score
listed on this slide
zero to three is a lactobacillus
predominate optimal vaginal flora four
to six is intermediate floor and seven
to ten is disappearance of the lactose
with numerous gardnerella vaginalis
mobile uncas and other strict anaerobes
the treatment of bv is listed on this
slide with the CDC 2015 guidelines I did
me I did mean to mention earlier that
we're going to have new CDC STD
treatment guidelines coming out in 2020
so those will be coming out probably in
the next 18 to 24 months so be on the
lookout for that so this whole thing
with BV treatment recurrence is very
common so women come in they get
diagnosed with BV they get treated with
one of those regimens recurrence is very
very common this one study published now
almost 12 years ago showed that at 28
weeks BV recurrence occurred in 51
percent of women they're honest
suppressant metronidazole therapy and
75% of women that were just on placebo
so those are very high recurrence rates
even in the face of suppressive therapy
so why is BV recurring so much in all
these women well it was recently
determined that BV is a biofilm
community and the biofilm is actually
what you're seeing on these clue cells
the clue cells are being slept off from
this biofilm which is basically a layer
of slime glycocalyx on the vaginal
aptitude
so alexander's was in ski in Germany was
one of the first to report on this BV
biofilm I have a picture of a clue cell
here with the biofilm and he found that
gardnerella vaginalis I'm actually going
to go to the next slide this is one of
the Sentinel studies on it Suez in ski
found that gardnerella vaginalis is the
bacteria that made up the majority of
the BV biofilm mass followed by a de
Peau B imagine a and much smaller
numbers of lactobacillus species which
makes sense because lactose are depleted
in a BV state so we basically think that
the BV biofilm is what's causing a lot
of treatment recurrence and that the
current currently recommended treatments
are not necessarily completely killing
the BV biofilm I do want to mention in
line with my discussion about BV being
an STD they have found in follow-up
studies with this BV biofilm that it
involves women and their male sexual
partners and here again people felt like
this biofilm is sexually transmitted in
these studies which also gives more
epidemiological evidence that BV is an
STD so this is an interesting study
looking at sexual transmission of this
BB biofilm between women their male
sexual partners and controls if you're
interested it was published in 2010 I'll
have it listed on this slide
so to improve BV recurrence rates the
current thought in the field is we need
to disrupt the biofilm so currently the
therapies use may not be doing this
effectively so it may be happening in
the future where we are treating women
with BV with more than one medication we
may be using an oral medication with an
intravaginal biofilm disrupting agent
for example so this may be something
coming down the pipeline in the future
there have been a few studies looking at
different agents to treat the BV biofilm
several of which I have listed on these
slides one is intravaginal boric acid
which has been used for BV in the past
it has also been used for vaginal yeast
infections and as I mentioned earlier
it's an anecdotal treatment for
refractory trichomoniasis so one study
has looked at intravaginal boric acid
they have a little bit of success with
it not a lot this was a very small study
it was not adequately powered and so
intravaginal boric acid right now is not
recommended in the CDC treatment
guidelines until much larger well
powered studies are included but it is a
potential option that needs to be
explored further another agent that's
been used is this agent called OCH 1009
Oxendine this has been used in one study
as a biofilm disrupting agent however it
was not very effective initial cure
rates were high but relapse was very
very high so I'm not sure you're going
to hear much more about this agent just
because this study did not show great
use of this medication with high relapse
rates another biofilm disrupting agent
is dnace which this has been found to
inhibit gardnerella vaginalis biofilms
in vitro and in vivo this is something
that may be looked at more in the future
and the most recent study which was
actually just published about two months
ago was a novel formulation of
intravaginal boric acid that is more
about this company toltec that was found
to be efficacious in treating women with
bv this boric acid agent is enhanced
with EDTA which the older intravaginal
boric acid preparation in that older
2009 study was not so that's the novel
part of this new study in this EDTA
specifically targets vaginal bacterial
and fungal biofilms and so they found
that using this special formulation of
the boric acid was able to treat a
substantial number of women with BV so
this could be a potential biofilm
disrupting agent in the future they have
not yet looked at it in women with
recurrent BV so that's something that
will be going on in the future
the last thing I wanted to mention
quickly is what about treating sexual
partners of women with BV that's
controversial right now right now the
2015 CDC STD treatment guidelines do not
recommend training partners of women
with BV this was based on the results of
prior clinical trials which I have
listed on this slide they're all male
partner treatment trials there's a six
of them
they've all been conducted in the 1980s
and the 1990s they were not conducted
rigorously five out of these six trials
did not show that treatment of the male
sexual partner
of women with recurrent BV was helpful
and because of these studies it is not
currently recommended to do that however
there was a meta-analysis of these
studies done in the sexually transmitted
diseases Journal in 2012 which found
that these studies have major issues all
of them in their methodologies and we
need new studies in the current error
that have rigorous methodologies to look
at this issue again particularly as we
think that BV is an STD to help sort
this issue out
only this one trial out of the six that
showed a partial effect of treating male
partners this study found that at two
and five weeks women whose partners were
treated with metronidazole were less had
less bv buy vaginal Gram stain on the
Nugent school and at eight weeks these
women whose partners are treated were
more likely to report resolution of
their BV symptoms but as you can see
this this study was done way back in
nineteen eighty nine the sample size was
small the results were presented
graphically they did not have effect
sizes in their study and even though
this study showed some positive results
because it was such a it was not
rigorously conducted the CDC treatment
guidelines did not recommend treatment
right now
I do want to call your attention to a
pilot study of male partner treatment
that was recently completed to look at
the acceptability of treating male
partners a study was done by Kat
Bradshaw and her group in Australia and
they only had 16 men in this study so it
was a small sample size women in the
study got oral metronidazole for several
seven days and they treated male sexual
partners for seven days with oral
metronidazole plus 2% topical [ __ ] of
ice and cream which they applied
topically to the head of the penis twice
daily for seven days note that this
study was done in Australia and they
treat VV there with 400 milligrams twice
a day for seven days a metronidazole not
500 milligrams as we do here in the
United States for the acceptability they
found that 88% of the men in the study
took over 90% of their tablets and 69%
applied over 90% of the clindamycin
doses so they did find that this
treatment was acceptable in these men
they did not have a lot of adverse
effects and they also found the impact
on the peano microbiota of using these
medications and men is that they reduced
a significant amount of BV associated
bacteria which they found in microbiome
specimens collected in this study this
is a an interesting study that but we
need more data on this topic
there is one well controlled
well-developed
randomized control trial of treatment of
the male sexual partners of women with
recurrent BV that is currently enrolling
in the United States and this study is
being done at Wayne State University in
Detroit and also here at UAB it's a
phase 3 study they've they've enrolled
200 plus women to date of the women in
the study have to have recurrent BV to
be enrolled they're getting seven days
and metronidazole for treatment and
their regular male sexual partner is
being randomized to placebo
or seven days of oral metronidazole the
primary outcome for the study is going
to be bv by am so scratch area and
Nugent score at sixteen weeks so these
couples are being followed long term and
I do also want to say I'm not I am not
immediately involved in this study one
of my colleagues here at UAB Jane
schweppe is doing the study but I have
been told that there is a couple's
verification tool used in the study to
make sure that these couples are
actually couples and not people that are
not couples because this can definitely
affect the the primary outcome it can
found the study results
I know I just went over a large amount
of information in a 50-minute period of
time I think we have about ten minutes
for questions and I'm happy to send this
back to our moderator and take any
questions that you may have thank you
thank you dr. Mudds me for your
informative presentation we will now
start the live Q&A portion of the
webinar if you have a question you'd
like to ask please do so now just click
on the answer a question box located on
the far left to your screen and we'll
answer as many of your questions as we
have time for so let's get started
our first question is from a patient
care perspective what are the most
common and peer treatments given to
patients with idiopathic signs of
vaginitis and what diagnostic or
clinical tools might reduce empiric
therapy in this era of antibiotic
stewardship so I think a patient
complaining of vaginal symptoms I would
definitely recommend that they go and be
seen by a provider it's been shown many
times in prior studies that a phone
diagnosis of a particular vaginal
infection is not correlated with exactly
what the patient has so I think the
patient would need to go into clinic and
get an exam or at least do a self
collected vaginal swab so we can at
least do a wet mount to see if they have
trichomonas and to see if they have an
SEL criteria and that way we can direct
our therapy based on what they have we
can also see the yeast forms on the wet
mount and the koh prep to diagnose a
vaginal yeast infection so in this
situation for vaginitis patient I think
they need an exam and they need a wet
mount at minimum to help determine
appropriate therapy
you
our next question from a Diagnostics
perspective is their consensus our
excuse me is our consensus in the field
for which analytes are most appropriate
for a molecular VD test there is not a
consensus in the field on that topic no
not that I'm aware of
all right let's move on to our next
question
to your knowledge does the not diagnosis
of tea badges of vaginal ballast differ
based on the life cycle stage of the
organism
like acid amplification test is going to
detect DNA of the organism and it does
not matter what stage of the lifecycle
that the organism is in if the organism
is there the test is going to detect it
now is there need for at home self
collected methods for diagnosis of
vaginitis associated passages and or BV
and how might these improve patient
access to care and/or impact the in
clinic demands of HCPs
I think obviously trichomonas is a major
issue in this country bacterial
vaginosis is as well so I think if there
were options for patients to self test
at home to get their results and call
their doctor to potentially get
treatment I think that would be great
right now I don't think that we're at
that point and for example for
trichomonas we have the rapid point of
care test that I mentioned which were
the wet mount and the awesome rapid
antigen test obviously the wet mount is
going to require someone to read that
under a microscope which patients are
not going to be able to do that the
rapid antigen test is currently only
being used in clinical settings to my
knowledge I'm not aware that that test
is commercially available so I do think
there is a need for that but I don't
think that we're there yet
dr. Bosley it looks like we have time
for one more question is there any
reason at all why the CDC guidelines for
treatment exclude male partners
ah are we talking about trichomonas or
BV um you know it's don't know
TV TV
for if this is if the question is about
trickle botas
the C&C guidelines actually do recommend
that male sexual partners of women with
trichomonas do get treated I'm sorry if
I did not say that earlier in my
presentation so we do know that
trichomonas is an STD and so all
partners of an infected woman should get
treated my comment earlier during my
presentation is that expedited partner
therapy where basically you give the
medication to the woman to distribute
herself to the partners it is not clear
how often that is being done in clinics
around the country and it's not
permissible in all states including my
state here in Alabama with regards to BV
the CDC guidelines currently do not
recommend treatment of male sexual
partners and that was based on the
negative results of the prior randomized
control trials of treatment of men but
as I mentioned those trials had multiple
methodological issues and we have that
new trial that's currently enrolling
here in the United States which can
hopefully once the data is available
from that trial can hopefully shed more
light on that issue to where it might
lead to a change in these
recommendations I hope that clarified
that question
Thank You dr. Maas me do you have any
final comments for for our audience I
think I covered a lot so I don't have
anything else right now thank you
thank you again dr. Christina Leslie for
your time today and your important
research we would also like to make
laberd's and our sponsor Roche molecular
diagnostics for other writing today's
educational webcast before we go I'd
like to thank the audience for joining
us today and for their interesting
questions questions we did not have time
for today and those submitted during the
on-demand period will be addressed by
the speaker via the contact information
you provided at the time of registration
this webcast can be viewed on-demand
through May of 2019 labret will alert
you via email when it's available for
replay we encourage you to share that
email with your colleagues who may have
missed today's live of it until next
time goodbye